جنود ايرلنديون من تجريده الامم المتحده
في لبنان يونيفيل كانوا في طريقهم من نطاق
عملياتهم في الجنوب الى مطار بيروت
طريقا اعتياديا عبر بلده العاقبيه التي
تقع ضمن نطاق نفوذ حزب الله لكنهم جوده
بشكل غير اعتيادي توجهت نحوهم مجموعه
مسلحه واطلقت النار عليهم ما ادى الى مقتل
احد الجنود واصابه عدد بجراح احدهم في
حاله خطيره
حفظ السلام في لبنان وجرح اخر انه تذكير
لنا بتضحيات غير العاديه التي يقدمها حفظه
السلام تابعونا لنا بشكل دائم انهم يعملون
في بعض الاحيان في بيئات المعاديه وصعبه
للغايه وخطيره ويجب ان يكون دائما على
وعين بذلك
بيئه غذائيه وصوره ضبابيه حول الهجوم الذي
سرعان ما قامت اليونيفيل بالتنسيق لمعرفه
اسبابه الحقيقيه التفاصيل قليله ومتضاربه
رغم ادانه الدوله اللبنانيه ودعوه التحقيق
الا ان مراقبين يستبعدون التوصل الى نتيجه
سريعه او حاسمه في ظل سيطره حزب الله الذي
سارع الى النائي بنفسه عن الحادث وتصوير
الهجوم كانه سوء تفاهم مع السكر
لكن على خط الموازين تجري قوات اليونيفيل
مع الجيش اللبناني تحقيقاتها بالحادث الذي
مازال يشربه الكثير من اللبس والمعلومات
المتضاربه